si hay algo que he estado haciendo toda
la vida prácticamente desde que nací a
dibujar
no recuerdo si miro para atrás ningún
momento en que no haya estado dibujando
dibujo todos los días
dibujo ilustraciones personajes
historietas dibujos para mi dibujo para
otras personas
esta sensación de dibujar es es algo
maravilloso es conectar el mundo de las
ideas que es invisible en desde este el
mundo físico estoy seguro de que entre
el público hay quienes dibujan
quienes dibujaron quienes lo hacen con
un interés serio y quienes lo hacen como
terapia
es realmente algo maravilloso cuando
somos chicos todos dibujamos
sin importar donde estemos ni qué idioma
hablemos todos dibujamos lápiz en la
mano movemos el brazo y sobre papel
aparece un trazo y es tal cuando somos
chicos alegría que nos da esto que a ese
ejercicio volvemos una y otra vez por
simple placer
parece que el dibujo saliera
directamente del brazo al papel
más adelante crecemos ya no somos tan
chicos y empezamos a adquirir esta
habilidad de ver imágenes en la cabeza
que queremos transferir al papel ahí se
comienza un entrenamiento un aprendizaje
donde tenemos que bajar lentamente la
imagen que tenemos en la cabeza al brazo
para luego pasar del brazo al papel
este aprendizaje no es fácil y se
requiere un carácter fuerte paciencia es
acá cuando nos abran la primera que es
la de jóvenes artistas que somos
y se escuchamos mucho es decir no puedo
dibujar lo perdí lo tenía y ya no lo veo
más ya no lo siento
se vuelve importante esta capacidad de
ver cosas en la cabeza y bajarlas a
través del brazo al papel tan importante
que como a todo lo que se vuelve
importante solemos darle un nombre
también le damos un nombre a esto y es
inspiración
se dice después de tanto usar esta
palabra y darle tanto peso que si no hay
inspiración no puede haber dibujos
yo dibujo todos los días
y tengo que confesarles que soy un
dibujante que dibuja todos los días sin
inspiración
o mejor dicho
dibujo todos los días pero sin depender
de la inspiración
a lo largo de mi vida he encontrado
algunas claves que hoy quisiera
compartir con ustedes que me permiten
evocar una tarea creativa sin depender
de que haya inspiración sino lo más
probable es que algunas tareas nos
terminen simplemente porque no hay
entonces quisiera compartir con ustedes
este camino de búsqueda personal de toda
una vida
afortunadamente comprimido en pocos
minutos
y desarrollado atacada y contarle las
claves que encontrado cuando era chico
yo dibujaba dibujaba como loco realmente
me lo pasaba dibujando y era tal la
alegría que me daba el ver aparecer un
trazo en el papel donde se movía mi
brazo
que eso me llevaba a repetirlo
tantas veces lo repetí que llegué a una
conclusión ese trazo aparecía porque yo
movía mi brazo en otras palabras yo era
el creador de ese trazo
cuando era chico
y se da cuenta de que crea cosas que
antes no estaban ahí
y no es poca cosa
realmente se siente como un superpoder
como todo superpoder recién adquirido se
lo someta a todo tipo de pruebas mi
prueba será mover el brazo de distinta
manera y veía que el trazo cambiaba
acorde a los movimientos que yo hacía no
solamente era creador sino que me
descubría como una persona que tenía
control voluntario sobre su propia obra
y está en la primera clave la acción
libre del brazo que me permite recorrer
dentro de mi papel todo tipo de
posibilidades que me da el dibujo
por entonces
yo tenía este poder y como todo poder y
de desafíos en algún momento
yo no fui la excepción un desafío es
básicamente alcanzar una meta a través
de una dificultad
mi meta eran dibujar cosas que no había
dibujado antes y mi dificultad era saber
cómo esto no se logra a simple vista es
necesario consultar referencias mis
referencias de entonces eran revistas
infantiles perdidas de historietas
dibujos animados de la televisión
por ese entonces se usaba un estilo
gráfico muy simple muy simplificado que
eran simples líneas y si la línea estaba
cerrada delimita un área y esa área
tenía un solo color
la ausencia total de sombras
esto hacía que yo dividiera el campo de
las artes en dibujos por un lado y
pinturas por otro para mí dibujos eran
líneas pinturas eran líneas con color en
las áreas cerradas por supuesto que ver
una pintura clásica a mí me provocaba
una confusión bastante importante porque
no calificaba en ninguna de las dos
categorías así todo por haber pintado a
mi dibujo yo me dedicaba más que nada a
la línea tiraba línea sobre papel y si
cada línea estaba bien ubicada bien
dibujada el dibujo todo habían hecho
no corregía no borraba no usaba la goma
un día decidí hacer historietas no sabía
cómo pero copiando de las referencias de
alguna manera lograba contar historias
en cuadritos de principio a fin con un
dibujo flojo débil
deshilachado
como mejora una mejora en el dibujo a
través de juntarse con otra gente que
maneja otro tipo de información yo me
encontré con historias de gestarse
aficionados que como yo trataban de
resolver sus historias cada uno aportaba
un pedazo de información que yo
desesperadamente trataba de meter en mi
propio dibujo pero al mismo tiempo esto
de entrar en contacto social con otras
personas hace inevitablemente que
aparezcan la crítica y la comparación
más de una vez me encontré siendo muchas
veces a las referencias de historietas
recién ya terminadas por otras personas
para incorporar eso en mi dibujo en mi
propio dibujo mi confianza empieza eso
entonces a tambalear frente a lo a la
solidez de otros ejemplos
esto se prolongó durante mucho tiempo al
punto de que mis intereses secundarios
empezaron a ganar más importancia con
respecto al dibujo en el momento de
elegir una carrera uno de mis intereses
secundarios que era la ciencia
tenía más importancia que el dibujo la
ciencia a mí me había parecido me
parecía entonces algo lejano misterioso
atractivo pero por comparación termine
anotando me en una carrera de ese de
ciencias me anoté en física la
universidad de buenos aires
es una de las ciencias duras requiere
una resistencia de cuerpo y mente
bastante especiales y una capacidad de
elaborar y desarrollar conceptos
abstractos en la cabeza y mi dibujo
quedó relegado a segundo o tercer plano
dibujaba en los pocos ratos libres que
la ciencia me dejaba más como
entretenimiento que como aprendizaje
esto me llevó a una crisis interna
importante donde
estaba sometido estaba dentro de un
conflicto entre lo que sentía que debía
hacer y lo que quería realmente hacer
como respuesta a esto me noté en una
segunda carrera alternativa de diseño
que fue para mí una verdadera brisa de
aire fresco
porque fue en ese ámbito que encontré
por primera vez profesores
contenidos todos organizados dentro de
una estructura que me contenía
y gracias a esto pude recuperar la
confianza en mi dibujo no abandoné y la
ciencia con esfuerzo logré graduarme
obtuve mi licenciatura y de paso terminé
la parte introductoria de esa segunda
carrera de diseño que si bien no lo
seguí como carrera
me demostró la segunda clave que es la
disciplina
todas esas horas interminables de
estudio que la ciencia me había dado me
ayudaron a mantenerme enfocado en
terminar lo que había empezado
seguí mi búsqueda personal entré a
trabajar en un estudio de animación que
era lo que siempre había querido hacer
cuando entrega el estudio de animación
descubrí que el nivel de dibujo que
tenían todos mis demás compañeros era
muy superior al mío
entonces me puse como loco a dibujar
horas y horas detrás del tablero
tratando de que mi nivel de dibujo
subiera y se pareciera a lo que dibujaba
en los demás subió por suerte y con el
tiempo me dieron puestos de mayor
responsabilidad y sale una vieja deuda
con la pintura de china
me dediqué a la pintura china en un
curso
en la pintura china uno se enfrenta un
papel de dimensiones más bien grandes
generosas ello hace que pasará y lo que
pasará de la mano y sentado a pasar a
pintar directamente con el brazo entero
y grande por primera vez estaba pintando
grande y suelto con un agregado muy
importante que es la preparación de la
propia tinta se prepara a la tinta con
un botón de partículas de carbón en
estado sólido que uno tiene que frotar
contra un recipiente con agua y así
prepara uno su propia tinta y esto
constituye la tercera clave del contacto
con los elementos
como trabajar en un estudio de animación
requiere ciertas normas que son
típicamente respetar el dibujo de un
personaje
a partir de normas que fija el cliente
mi dibujo era bueno en la medida que se
parecía el dibujo de los demás
todos teníamos que dibujar igual
uno entrega a su parte del trabajo y se
pierde en la vorágine de la producción y
a veces lo ve terminado a veces no
[Música]
viendo que yo tenía una restricción de
mi libertad creativa porque yo no puedo
dibujar el personaje como a mí se me
ocurra como sienta
y viendo que seguían acumulándose las
horas detrás del tablero busco una
actividad física para física del cuerpo
para balancear tantas horas y encontré
cerca de mi lugar de trabajo un lugar
donde dictaban taekwondo que es un arte
marcial muy moderno me anoté enseguida y
pasé de estas normas un poco
restrictivas de el estudio de animación
cuyo resultado a veces no se ve o se ve
mucho después a un protocolo marcial
el protocolo marcial está diseñado para
otorgarle beneficios al estudiante de
artes marciales dentro de la propia
sesión de entrenamiento el saludo
típicamente que uno tiene que ofrecerle
obligatoriamente a las graduaciones
mayores apenas se entra al lugar resulta
ser el mismo que el que me daban las
graduaciones menores
esto me daba el beneficio de que no
importará quién me pusieran delante para
practicar en esa hora de entrenamiento
nos beneficiábamos mutuamente en un
clima de respeto mutuo
entonces resumidas hasta acá mis cinco
claves que hoy les voy a presentar en
forma ordenada como el kit de
supervivencia para cualquier persona que
se aboque a tareas creativas
rápidamente el calentamiento el
calentamiento es el ejercicio básico de
la parte del cuerpo mecánico que voy a
usar en la tarea para mí es típicamente
la mano para un pintor será todo el
brazo para un escultor los dos brazos
para una bailarina todo el cuerpo el
calentamiento tiene la ventaja de que
rompe o vence la inercia del reposo nos
saca del reposo nos pone en un estado de
movimiento desde el cual alcanzar la
acción intensa lo hacemos con energía
organizada y en un mínimo de tiempo
a través de la comunión o la unión común
con los elementos que no es otra cosa
que la integración con las herramientas
de trabajo sacarle punta a un lápiz
calzarse unas zapatillas de baile ubicar
un lienzo delante de una ventana hago
trabajar los sentidos típicamente vista
tacto y oído los sentidos son
transmisores de información atemporales
trabajan centrados en el aquí y el ahora
esto tiene la ventaja de que me olvido
de las preocupaciones del pasado y de
las eventuales angustia del futuro en
otras palabras libera mi pensamiento
para abocar me de lleno a la tarea a
través de la acción libre puedo explorar
el espacio de las posibilidades que me
da el dibujo
pintura baile lo que sea a través de la
repetición preparó el terreno para el
momento el lugar el modo en que se puede
presentar una idea porque si algo tiene
la inspiración es que es de naturaleza
inesperada
a través de normas y protocolos observo
conductas beneficiosas para mi tarea
típicamente cuando empiezo cuando
termino cuánto debe durar una tarea
ordenar las herramientas una vez que
termino o dejarlas tiradas depende de la
actitud y barrer el lugar de trabajo y
por último a través de la disciplina
tengo la capacidad de atender una
llamada telefónica de bajar a recibir un
pedido y cuando subo retomar la tarea en
el punto exacto donde la dejé sin que
esa interrupción se haya convertido en
una distracción
estas claves
prepara el terreno para la llegada de la
inspiración pero de ninguna manera
aseguran su llegada si cuando la
inspiración aparece me mantengo enfocado
en mantener estas claves funcionando
lo más probable es que ella pase de ser
una nebulosa sin concierto sin perón sin
contornos definidos
a que se acerque es por si sola y se
muestre como una criatura plena de luz
llena de colores detalles
en ese caso habré pasado de el deseo de
querer atrapar la inspiración con la
escurridiza y frágil que es
a prepararle una adecuada bienvenida
sabiendo de antemano que tranquilamente
puede dejarnos plantados si eso ocurre
nadie va a poder decirnos que no hemos
estado haciendo nuestra parte
entonces señoras y señores - inspiración
y más transpiración o como dijera el
pintor español pablo picasso la
inspiración existe pero tiene que
encontrarnos trabajando muchas gracias
[Aplausos]